want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
motivation from jordan peterson
enjoy
treat yourself like you're someone that
you care about see i read this
i read this this piece of work by jung a
long while back and he it was a
meditation on
um the injunction to treat your neighbor
as as you would like to be treated
something like that and what jung
pointed out which i really liked was
that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people
it was an invitation to reciprocity it
was something like this
it's like you should figure out how you
would like to be treated
like you were taking care of yourself
not how you would like people to respond
to you
it's more important than that it's like
imagine you had a child that you really
cared for
and and someone said well people will
treat this child exactly
like you want them to but you have to
figure out what that is and so then
you'd have to sit down for like a month
and you'd think okay well
how do you want your child to be treated
you don't want everyone just to be nice
to him you know you want people to
challenge him and you want people to
discipline him and
you want people to tell him when he's
wrong it's like you don't just want
everyone to be nice that's that's
pathetic
it's pathetic isn't there's no challenge
in that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and well you'd like people to fawn all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's that's not something you'd wish
for for someone that you were taking
care of
and then then there's an additional
problem which is it's often the case
that people will treat other people
better than they treat themselves that
happens extremely
frequently so one of the things i
pointed out chapter two was that
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you
your prescription medicine you'll go buy
the medicine and you will give it to the
dog and you will do it properly
but if you go yourself to a doctor and
you get a
prescription there's one that there's a
30 chance you won't even pick up the
medication
and if you do there's a 50 chance that
you won't administer it to yourself
properly
and so i really thought about that when
i first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts i thought what
is up with that it's like you'll do it
for your dog so
obviously you'll do it for something you
care about
and you're conscientious enough so
you'll actually do it so like
why wouldn't you do it for you your dog
likes you you know even your dog would
rather that you did but but you don't
you don't
and and it's actually one of the reasons
that modern medicine doesn't work nearly
as well as it could because people just
don't take their medication
you make the world a much better place a
much worse place if you don't take care
of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapters about it's
partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that western
civilization has always recognized that
as an individual
you have a light that you have to bring
into the world and that if you don't
bring it into the world
the world is a dimmer place and that's a
bad thing because when the world is a
dim place it can get very very very dark
and so it's not just so that you feel
better and not just so that you're a
number one lobster not none of those
things
you need to take care of yourself
because you're in the best position to
do that
and it's necessary for you to take care
of yourself despite the fact that
we're mortal and vulnerable and
self-conscious and capable
not only capable of doing terrible
things but actually do them despite all
that
you you're still you still have that
responsibility
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday
not to who someone else is today and the
reason i wrote that was because
i had this client 10 i'm a clinical
psychologist and i spent
20 hours a week for 25 years listening
to people
listening to people tell me about their
lives you know and and those people were
people who were just barely hanging on
to the bottom of the world
up to people who were so successful you
can hardly believe it like the entire
gamut of
people and and that's been absolutely
fascinating it's like
it's like being a clinical psychologist
if you really listen is like
being immersed in a dostoevsky novel all
the time
you know because it's amazing what
people will tell you if you listen to
them
they are people are so interesting if
you actually listen to them because
they're so peculiar like
they're like penguins or rhinoceroses
and ostriches they're
unlikely creatures and anyways
um with regards to um
to uh comparing yourself to who you were
yesterday and not just
who someone else is today um this old
client of mine
he was about 85 when he came to see me
and he was a financier and a kind of a
mathematical genius he made these little
pendants out of a a mathematical symbol
for the most beautiful
mathematical equation that was ever
written that he made them out of gold
and he would hand those out and
and he had studied psychology as a young
man
and he introduced me to this concept
that i didn't know about called the
pareto distribution which
see i'd been taught as a psychologist
that most human characteristics
were normally distributed right so most
people were average and some people were
extreme that that's a pretty or a normal
distribution
intelligence is like that and height
there's more people of
average height than very tall or very
short and weight is like that and
lots of things are normally distributed
and psychologists tend to assume that
everything is but it isn't
creative products are distributed in a
pareto distribution and that's a whole
different thing and it's really
important to know this it's another
fundamental
fact the knowledge of which can sort of
transform the way you conceptualize
let's say
the political landscape so here here's
an example of the pareto distribution
huh
you know there's a rule of thumb that if
you run a company that twenty percent of
your employees do eighty percent of the
work
or the twenty percent of your customers
are responsible for eighty percent of
your sales
or the 20 of them are responsible for 80
of the customer
service calls same thing but that's not
exactly the rule the rule is worse than
that
the rule is in a given domain
the square root of the number of people
operating in that domain do
half the productive work so you think
well you have 10 employees three of them
do half the work it's like yeah
okay what if you have 100 employees then
10 of them do half the work
what if you have a thousand employees
well then it's 30
and if it's 10 000 employees then it's a
hundred
and this actually turns out to be a
rather ironclad rule it
it applies across very very many
situations it applies
for example to the mass of stars and the
size of cities
so you can see how universal it is as a
law and it's it's something like those
that have
more get more and those that have less
get less that's the matthew principle
right
to those who have everything more will
be given from those who have nothing
everything will be taken away and the
economists sometimes call that the
matthew principle and
so what what that lays out is a world
that's rife with inequality so you know
you you hear this
idea that i think it's the 85 richest
people in the world
have more money than the bottom 2
billion that's a pareto distribution
phenomena
and you might say to hell with
capitalism for producing that
it's like sorry you got your diagnosis
wrong it's a natural law
it's no matter what society you study
you get a pareto distribution of wealth
you get a pareto distribution of number
of records recorded you get a pareto
distribution of number of songs written
or goals scored like
any creative product has that
characteristic and it's partly because
as you start to become successful let's
say
people offer you more and more
opportunities and as you start to fail
people move away from you and you
plummet
and so okay so that's rough so what it
is what it means is that there is always
a landscape of inequality
and i'm not saying that we shouldn't do
anything about it although i am saying
that we don't know what to do about it
that's the thing you know because you
can modify the pareto distribution
of wealth let's say but if you but we
don't know how to do it without maybe
disrupting the system so completely that
it collapses
which is what happened in the soviet
union for example and in maoist china
they were trying at least in principle
to adjust inequality
but the cure was far worse than the
disease and the the truth of the matter
is we actually don't know
technically how much inequality there
has to be to generate wealth
we can guess and you could say well
there should be less and you might say
well there should be more
if you're left-wing you'd say less and
if they're if you're right-wing you'd
say well we'll just let the inequality
flourish
but we do know that it's inevitable and
we also know that we don't know how to
regulate it so
there is inequality what that means is
there's always going to be people around
that are better at something than you
are and the and that's a that's a
problem because you can get jealous and
you can get bitter and you can get
resentful
and worse you can get hopeless you know
because you look like look
i have this this friend of mine he told
me something so funny
he was he was decrying his his lack of
success
in the world and he compared himself to
his roommate
and uh he said you know his roommate his
college roommate was doing much better
than he was
and his bloody roommate was elon musk
it's like
really like it's like oh you're not
doing as well as elon musk
well it's i mean you can see it would
take it rather personally because they
were roommates and everything
it wasn't like he was doing badly like
he was doing pretty damn well it's like
i'm not as good as elon musk it's like
yeah well you and
like seven billion other people you know
but
but i thought it was instructive because
well because
you have to be careful who you compare
yourself to now you can't
just not compare yourself to others to
successful people right because then you
don't have anything to email when you're
trying to lead people forward out of the
darkness let's say
out of anxiety and depression and
despair and and resentment bitterness
and anger and all of those things
catastrophic interactions with their
family
is that you get them to stop avoiding
confronting the terrible things that are
in front of them right so basically what
you do instead of saying to them
you know those terrible things that are
happening just ignore those and
and find some peace right get your mind
away from it that is what you say
you say turn around and look at them
even more than you've been looking at
them
it's very paradoxical advice but of all
the things that have been proven
to aid people's recovery and movement
towards mental health that's
like at the top of the list voluntary
confrontation with what you are afraid
of
or or what you despise even for that
matter
and so jung had an axiom that he derived
from the alchemist
which was instir qualis inventor which
meant
roughly meant that which you most need
will be found where you least want to
look
which is yeah well that's here that was
also his explanation for why people
weren't enlightened
because you think well the california
approach to enlightenment to speak you
know kind of satirically is follow your
bliss
it's like well that's easy if that was
the case everyone would be enlightened
but the union approaches no no no you do
what's meaningful and
pay attention follow the truth and it
will take you to the worst place you can
imagine
and then maybe there's some chance for
enlightenment one of the fundamental
theses
of 12 rules for life and also of maps of
meaning is that
because life is essentially tragic in
its fundamental essence
you need a sustaining meaning that's
deep
and and profound and deep and profound
enough to get you through
bad times because there will be very bad
times in your life there'll be death and
there'll be illness and
there'll be disappointment of of all
sorts and
and there'll be just the standard
difficulties of life in the world to
contend with and
you really must have something
that's profound and powerful to set up
against that and
i think that your voluntary adoption of
the struggle to improve being is the
proper
uh antidote to that also if you want to
have more confidence self love self
belief check out my 254 series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special free
program to help you get it where i will
send you an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self belief forward the link to
sign up for free is in the description
below
if you're going to speak effectively
you have to know way more than you're
talking about you have to treat yourself
like you matter
because if you don't then you don't take
care of yourself and you become vengeful
oh no you're okay you should feel good
about yourself like you're you're fine
the way you are it's like you think well
that's a calming message for people it's
like no it's not
it's hard to say what the soul means
metaphysically because
you know say beyond the cons beyond the
confines of a single human being
we do have this sense that the soul can
expand itself into something that's
greater than well greater than it has
been it has this capacity for growth
and we do have the sense that the soul
can
expand itself to the point where it it's
enlightened for lack of a better word
that it's working
as efficiently as possible to transform
everything that's
unnecessarily painful and malevolent
about the world
into what's positive and good and and
and that it does that as a consequence
of confronting the world with courage
and truth
and i i think that's right and i do
think that that means that the soul
participates in something eternal
which is the attempt of being itself
to transform what's unnecessarily
painful and malevolent into what's good
and that human beings
actually do participate in that and that
that's part of
the reason that our ancient tradition
insists
that we're made in the image of god
and i think that it's a mistake to
underestimate
the importance of that because i don't
think that you can live
life a life of sufficient profundity
to protect yourself from being corrupted
by suffering
malevolence without adopting
a responsibility that's commensurate
with that set of ideas
i think that you either
orient yourself upward you know to the
star above the horizon
and try desperately to improve
the structure of being or you work
at counter purposes to it and make
things worse
i don't think there's a middle ground
and in fact
to the degree there is a middle ground
it tilts towards the negative because
people who try to occupy the middle
ground
try to generally try to
accrue the benefit let's say without
adopting any of the risk and that's not
acceptable not helpful so
that's a soul to me if you're having a
discussion with someone
and they're talking about things that
don't have those characteristics right
that they haven't made
personal then the conversation is almost
never interesting
it's because the person is it's just
they're just they really are an empty
shell through which
ideologue ideology cliches and slogans
are pouring
there's nothing about that that's
compelling because you don't
see the grappling
you don't see that the other person has
grappled with the ideas and come to
their own
unique conclusions and it really is in
that
mingling of the abstract and the
particular that
compelling wisdom is to be found and so
that's
that's and then concretely speaking
well there's ways of earning your
knowledge and part of that is
reformulating it in your own words
that's thinking it through right
and discussing it until you have it at
hand
you can talk about it and you can
generalize from it because you truly
understand it
but a huge part of that is also putting
it into practice and deriving
your own conclusions as a consequence
and some of that can be done
with debate it's like here's an idea i
came across and
here's the idea and here's what i think
it means and
this is how i think it would change
things if i put it into practice this is
how i understand this
idea and what do you think of that like
that's a good
debate or discussion you know because
then the other person can say well
i don't really agree with the way you
formulated that or i don't agree with
your conclusions and
hopefully it's a real discussion and not
just one-upmanship you know because
that's a pretty dull game
seoul is also the center of the world
which is a frightening proposition and
not one that's easily comprehensible
solzhenitsyn's work in the gulag
archipelago is particularly enlightening
in this regard
because he insisted that it was a pre
preconception of our judeo-christian
heritage that each person was the center
of the cosmos and
you can think of that as a center of
consciousness right
a center from which being itself is not
only reflected but also generated and
it was solzhenitsyn's belief and
dostoevsky's as well and
i think jung would have been in
accordance with this and nietzsche as
well
for that matter that in some manner that
we don't fathom
because we don't understand the
structure of the world very well
the outcome of
the world is dependent on our choices
and and equally on all of our choices
and it i don't understand i know that's
i know that to be true i feel that to be
true
it's it's part of the doctrine that each
person is of
intrinsic and equal worth
part of that doctrine is that each
person is has
intrinsic and equal responsibility
and that we're each capable of
generating a fair bit of hell
around us and for other people but also
capable of generating a tremendous
amount of good
and that the fate of the world as it
careens through
eternity is actually a consequence of
the ethical decisions of each of us it's
a terrifying idea
it's no wonder people flee from it into
hedonism let's say and
and ideology because it's very
frightening possibility that
the choices that you make day to day or
fail to make
have this profound and lasting effect on
the structure of reality but
i don't really see any way out of that
conclusion one of the
things i've thought about a fair bit is
the meaning of the sermon on the mount
and as far as i can tell it's it's a
it's basically a two-part it's two-part
wisdom
the first is that you should aim at the
highest good that you can imagine
and that would be a good that includes
everyone right so
if i wanted what was good for you say if
i genuinely wanted it
i'd want it in a way that was good for
you now and good in the long run and
good for you and your family and your
community and
maybe good for me too you know you could
conceive of that as the desire
and i think that's a good definition of
love is that you actually want the best
you want the best possible outcome and
in the gospels of course that's extended
even to your enemies
yes right is that okay if we're gonna
have things good let's have it good
enough for even the people that set
themselves up against me because if the
world was
running properly things would be good
for them too and that would be better
and it seems to me that that's a very
good way of looking at things it's a
difficult way of looking at things
and then the second part of the sermon
on the mount is something like
having established that as your aim
which is no
easy thing by the way right because you
have to be pretty clear-headed and
single-minded to
actually want that to be your aim then
you can concentrate on the day and you
can try telling the truth
and you can ally so there's truth and
love that are allied together truth love
and attention it's something like that
that are all allied together
with regards to transgressing against
the vulnerable
if you're plagued by boats of depression
and anxiety that does destabilize your
identity
so um it's almost by definition
but having said that look this is when
habit and plan
and strategy are so useful so in the
periods of depression that i've had
what's sustained some of them were long
and and and
certainly the most unpleasant
experiences of my life
um you this is when you need
a philosophy let's say that's allied
with your vision and your strategy to
sustain you because
what what what would happen to me is
that
i know i have these a vision and i
suppose the vision is
of a world that's better in
in that's less likely to descend into
ideological catastrophe
and where people are more responsible
and more awake
and more educated and and and healthier
all of that a vision of a better world
you know a world that's less hellish at
least
but also a better world and some sense
of what role
i might play in that and and so that's
very motivating like it's a profound
goal
to try to make things better and you can
do that locally you can do that for
yourself you can do that for your family
you can do that for the broader
community and all of that's worth it man
it's worth making some sacrifices for
it's worth suffering for
to some degree and then you decompose
that into the
day-to-day and week-to-week strategies
and actions that you're undertaking the
plans and
and and the activities that you're
putting forward to make that
dream a reality to realize it and then
when the depression and anxiety come
along you think
part of it with depression it's like
it's just bloody endurance it's like
you get up and you work through the next
hour you try to
stay on track you try to implement your
strategic plans
to the best of your ability and you hope
and you pray that
you'll get through it you know you'll
get through it and that the darkness
will recede
and you you you stay on track
you eat even though you're not hungry
you get up even though you
want to stay in bed you interact with
people even though you'd rather be alone
and it's it's it's it's the benefit
of disciplined habits can
can sustain you it's like the boat
you're rowing in
through a terrible storm leaks and all
and maybe you'll be
overwhelmed but you have the boat and
you can roll forward and
that's what you've got and so endurance
is a huge part of it
and then i would say with its anxiety
it's the same thing it's like
are very much the same as you're
terrified and
and uncertain but you move ahead to the
best of your ability
and again you operate at least to some
degree on hope and if you haven't got
hope then you've got blind bloody
endurance
and that's all motivated by some sense
that you're working towards something
that's worthwhile working toward
you know and and that is well that's
your own long-term well-being
to treat yourself properly it's the
stability and productivity
and harmony and health of your family
that's a huge deal
and then it's whatever benefit you can
be to the community
and if you have to limp along and drag
yourself forward
in order to maintain that pathway then
so be it
because it's better than the alternative
higher on the basis of competence
using objective tests and let the cards
fall where they're going to
and don't be afraid to tell people
that that's what you're doing watch your
hr department carefully and make sure
that
they're not pushing diversity
inclusivity and equity initiatives that
they're not requiring
people to take implicit association
tests that hypothetically reveal their
unconscious bias
that they're not doing seminars on
systemic racism and prejudice
and then they're not making the
assumption that unequal outcomes
let's say in terms of hiring in the stem
fields or in terms of employment in the
stem fields which by the way are
radically overestimated if you
unless you gerrymander what constitutes
the definition of a stem discipline
you just have to you have to not
participate in any of that
and you have to make it known to your
peers which who would be other silicon
valley founders i would presume
that you're not doing any of that you
need an ideal because you have nothing
to aim at but an ideal is a judge
and you always fall short of the ideal
so how the hell can you have the
benefits of having an ideal
without having the crushing blow that
goes along with having the judge that
always regards you as insufficient
so i was trying to work that out in the
chapter and this is something i've had
to work out a lot as a clinical
psychologist it's like
well let's say you need a goal
but we don't want to let your distance
from the goal crush you
so you've got to set up a goal and then
you've got to make the goal
break the goal down into parts so that
you can move towards it you have a
fairly high likelihood of doing it
so that's a bit of practical i wouldn't
say advice it's it's
because it's better than advice it's
it's some practical knowledge about
how to go about achieving an aim set a
high aim
but differentiate it down so you know
what the next step is
and then make the next step difficult
enough so you have to push yourself past
where you are
but but also provide yourself with a
reasonable probability of success
it's also what you do with children
right you you want to push them because
they need to grow up and be more than
they are right but you don't want to
crush them with constant failures so
what you do is
aim high and make the goal proxy
difficult but proximal
i think a tremendous amount of what you
might regard as
shadow integration which in
the parlance of behavioral psychologists
would be something like assertiveness
training
right it's training in how to stand up
for yourself and and for your
let's say for your better self which
would be the self that you could use
productively over a medium to long
period of time
that would be of use to you but also
views to people around you
so it's a self that's bounded by the
necessity
of taking care of yourself but also
simultaneously taking care of the people
around you
um
i i think that the simplest way to start
that work is to consult your resentment
you know it's easy to become bitter
about life and to become angry
because of course life is difficult and
it's full of disappointments
and people are also subject to betrayal
on the part of themselves and on the
part of people that hypothetically care
for them and so it's easy to get
bitter and to be resentful and
resentment is a very useful emotion even
though i think it's one of the most
damaging emotions if it's not dealt with
properly so
if you're resentful basically means
only one of two things it either means
you should grow up and quit whining
and get on with your life or it means
that
you're being subject to tyrannical
forces
of one form or another maybe emanating
from you may be a consequence of the
natural environment maybe a consequence
of society
you're being subject to tyrannical
forces and you're not
uh putting your own best
interests forward like in that broader
sense that i described
and i don't mean your selfish narrow
interests that only serve
the purposes of instantaneous
gratification i mean
your own best interests in terms of
developing your character over the span
of your life
if you're resentful it either means that
you're immature and that you should grow
the hell up
and so you need to figure out how much
of your resentment is is
is that and and maybe allied with the
desire to find other
things or people to blame but the other
possible option is that
you have something to say or do right
because you're in a situation
where you're violating your own internal
ethical standards
and you're being required pressured
let's say to say things you don't
believe or to do things that you believe
to be wrong and you need to
determine you need to start to
strategize and plan
how you can rectify that so that you can
say what you mean like if you're
negotiating with a marital partner for
example and there are
um issues in your marriage that aren't
making you happy
well the first thing is you have to take
note of that right to see that you're
actually unhappy
the second is that you have to be
willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to sort out
what's disturbing you you're going to
have to lay your concerns out on the
table
and say well look this is bothering me
you don't have to say well
i'm right and you're wrong and you have
to fix this you have to say well i've
noticed that
this pattern of interaction
or lack of interaction say in our
relationship
is making me resentful and angry and
the danger of that of course is you're
going to take it out on yourself and
your partner
the danger is passion passive
aggressiveness you know you're not going
to respond to your partner positively
when they do something good if you're
resentful about them
and you're not going to respond to
yourself properly and so you have to lay
it out on the table but sort of in a
spirit
of ignorant humility it's like look i'm
frustrated i'm feeling this way
about our relationship here's what i
think might be going wrong
maybe on my part and maybe on your part
and here's
what i envision as a possible solution
that's also really necessary
if you're going to say what you have to
say which is to manifest yourself
properly in the world is you can't just
complain about what's wrong
you have to think well what would my
minimal preconditions for satisfaction
be
you have to offer that to the person
that you're negotiating with
and so then you learn to abide by
the truth to the degree that you can do
that and no one does it perfectly
you know but it it's very useful because
you're not storing up a whole
sequence of memories about how you were
unfairly treated and abused and betrayed
instead you're trying to stay on top of
it and to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself
and to accept that that's the case and
then to analyze that to see if it's your
problem
like i said with regards to maturity or
if it indicates that
there's an injustice in the manner in
which
you and the world are interacting and
then to work to set that right even in
small ways and
so it's it's a matter of character
logical development and that makes you
that makes you stronger over time and
partly what you need you know in order
to do that is you have to really
understand and
we do this this is why we built in the
future authoring program we built this
section where you have to outline
your most dismal future right what your
future would be like if you let all your
bad habits and
characterological weaknesses have the
upper hand and the reason we did this is
because
you can't be uh you can't straighten
yourself out
merely as a consequence of hope let's
say you lay out a vision for the future
and you think about what your life would
be
what you'd like your life to be like and
then that makes you hopeful and it
motivates you because it gives you
something
worthwhile and higher order to work for
right
and that's useful that's positive
emotion working for you because
positive emotion is experienced in
relationship to goals but it's not
not as useful as also being chased by
something you're terrified by
and if you have a good sense of how
you'd fall apart if you stayed weak
and just exactly what kind of hell that
would be then
when you determined to do something like
to tell the truth and to say what you
think and to not do things that you hate
then you're going to be pulled along by
the purpose that your vision has
provided for you but also
pushed along by your desire to avoid the
worst forms of hell that you've already
outlined for yourself personally
and that can also help you be brave
enough to stand up
in a situation that we would require
conflict because
if you have something to say and you
have something to negotiate
about with someone then there's going to
be a certain amount of conflictual
dialogue that accompanies that right
it to to lay out a set of problems and
to
describe the fact forthrightly that
those problems characterize a
relationship and then to seek for
solutions
is quite stressful in the short term and
it's really easy to avoid and so people
avoid it all the time and then they
store up grievances
across the span of their relationships
and eventually the grievances mount to
the point where they return
in monstrous form and just eat
everything up that's where you get
divorces
or that's where you explode at your boss
and end up fired or
that's where you you know you develop
high blood pressure over 15 years
because you can't stand all the
accumulated
uh mons all the accumulated monsters in
your closet and
then you drink yourself into oblivion
because he can't stand your life
that's all you know very
counterproductive
but it's easy to avoid that necessary
conflict on a moment-to-moment basis
because
it's very stressful to speak
forthrightly about genuine conflicts
especially when you're dealing with
important parts of your life
but otherwise you don't straighten them
out and then you have to carry all that
forward so you need to be terrified of
the consequences of not
speaking your piece and that can
counterbalance the terror
of actually trying to have a
conversation you want to present
yourself to the world
in a manner that that doesn't disgrace
you in some sense that that might be a
good way to think about it and
you don't want to disgrace yourself
because the consequence of disgrace is
emotional dysregulation
more pain less positive emotion and so
the best way to present yourself is to
stand up forthrightly
and to stretch out you know and to
occupy some space
and to to to you make yourself sort of
vulnerable by doing that because you
open up the front of your body right
but it's a sign of confidence and that
way people are most likely to give you
the benefit of the doubt
and that's a good way to start
regulating your mood but not only does
it directly regulate your mood to stand
up
because it's so tightly associated like
posture reflection is associated with
serotonin and emotional regulation
but also because if you straighten up
and you present yourself in that manner
then other people are more likely to
take you seriously
and that means they'll start treating
you as if you're a number one lobster
instead of a number 10 lobster
and that's another way that you can at
least give yourself the bloody benefit
of the doubt right
and and and and and and and confront the
world in a courageous manner
add small goals now
if that doesn't work like if you can't
make the goals small enough to achieve
you know it might be that you're not
being humble enough with regards to your
conceptions of your own ability
but you can tell if the goal that you
put forward is
a reasonable one if you're actually
implementing it because if you're not
then by definition it's not a reasonable
goal
you know like let's say you're you're
sleeping all the time in your room is
just a bloody complete
disaster you know and you think well i
should clean up my room it's like well
maybe you can't
but maybe tomorrow you could hang up two
shirts you know
or you could you could move two shirts
from your bedroom to the laundry room
or you could bag up a bag of dirty
clothes that you could conceivably take
to a laundromat
and you just do that one thing you know
if you do
if your room's a catastrophe and you do
that one thing
and then you did one thing like that for
15 days or 20 days
maybe your place would be in order and
so the trick is to get the trajectory
right
i think that the best approach to
ameliorating inequalities to strengthen
the individual
i mean that's and that's what i've
concentrated on doing like we have this
program
uh the self-authoring suite and there's
a component of that that helps people
write an autobiography
and another component that helps them
write an analysis of their personality
and another component that helps them
write out a plan for the future
and we've used that we've studied the
effect of having people write out a
detailed plan for their future
and it's a proper plan it's like okay
look you
you get to have what you want three to
five years down the road you get to have
the friends you want you get to have the
family you want you get to have the
career you want the education
you get you get to take care of yourself
properly you get to
withstand the temptations of drug and
alcohol
abuse and other sorts of impulsive
pleasures you get to make productive and
meaningful use of your time
okay what does that look like for you
write it out
what does it look like just you need a
vision and then you need another vision
of how terrible things could be if you
let all your bad habits get the upper
hand
and we've had people do that in an
experimental situation and
mostly they were college students and
the consequences of that there were two
consequences
one was general which was that
university students were about 30
percent more likely to stay in
university and got grades there were
about 25 percent better
which is a walloping effect but even
more interestingly and this is the
coolest thing i think that we ever
discovered as
in our in our psychological research
we did this research in holland at the
um
at the erasmus university in rotterdam
at the rotterdam school of management
and we ran business
students through the future authoring
program for multiple years so
several thousands of them and we
stratified them by gender
and ethnicity pretty a pretty rough cut
men and women and then dutch nationals
and non-western ethnic minorities
okay and so the the performance was like
this the dutch women were at the top
then the dutch men then the then the
non-western ethnic minority women then
the non-western ethnic minority men
and they were behind the dutch women by
by
by they they should about an 80 percent
decrement in performance really
quite catastrophic two years after they
did the future authoring program they
were ahead of the dutch women
it just blew us away because it was and
it was a perfect indication
of the fact that you can use a
psychological intervention
to ameliorate what looks like a
sociological problem of course you
struggle to remember it in your
day-to-day life because
life is difficult and it's harder to do
things than not to do them and it's
harder to do them well than to do them
badly
you know and it's easy to sit around and
be hopeless i don't mean it's
emotionally easy because it's not
but it's procedurally easy to be useless
and
to fall back into your old habits and to
not discipline yourself and
it's a matter of continual practice slow
continual practice
and i think a good example of that is
something like weight lifting you know
if you start a weight lifting program
which i would recommend by the way
because
it it's tremendously advantageous
physically
and cognitively you're not going to
really see results for a number of weeks
and then the results are rather slow but
you can get pretty decent results over a
six-month period and absolutely stellar
results over a couple of years and so
you have to make sure your time frame is
right and not to be too hard on yourself
and
i did mention the future authoring
program
um earlier and one of the things i would
recommend too is if you're having a hard
time
implementing your your decisions say
your ethical decisions
that you spend a bit more time thinking
them through and writing them down and
the future authoring program is really
helpful for that that's why we designed
it
and so get your goals straight and
continue to practice
every day and if you're not succeeding
then make your goals slightly smaller
you want to you want to make your goals
large enough
so that they challenge you but small
enough so that you have a reasonable
probability of succeeding at them on a
day-to-day basis
and then you have to also understand
that if you fail on a given day
like let's say you're trying to quit
smoking and you quit for two weeks and
then you have a cigarette and you think
oh my god now i've screwed it up i've
i'm not quitting anymore
you smoke a whole pack of cigarettes
it's like well
there's a couple of mistakes there and
one is
well just because you had a cigarette
doesn't mean you failed
it just means that you had a cigarette
you can start stopping again
the next day and the fact that you had
one cigarette in the last two weeks is a
hell of a lot better than the two weeks
that you had before that
and so you've got to be realistically
humble
you've got to be ambitious enough in
your goals so that you're pursuing
something that you regard as truly
meaningful and worthwhile
you know and maybe you can judge that to
some degree if you think about someone
you love attempting the same thing and
think about how you would feel if they
managed it and if you would feel good
then
that's probably a good um what would you
say that would be a good
evaluation strategy to use on yourself
so you want your goals to be of
sufficient nobility so that you can live
with yourself
properly if you're pursuing them but you
want them to be small enough so that you
have a reasonable probability of
implementing them
i talk to people about taking care of
themselves like they're someone
who they have responsibility for and
that's not a political issue
too it's it's uh it's an injunction to
assuming that you have a certain
intrinsic value
you know and that it's necessary for
that value to manifest itself
for you to push yourself against the
world to challenge yourself
because otherwise what you're capable of
won't manifest itself it has to be
developed it has to be
called forth by necessity right you have
to pick a hard problem and try to solve
it and push yourself against it
in order for and you have to try to do
that truthfully and responsibly
in order for what it is that you're
intrinsically
capable of and composed of to come to
the forefront
and that seems like a very positive
thing as far as i'm concerned to
encourage people to be responsible for
themselves and for other people and also
to point out that
that you have a moral responsibility to
do so
for yourself just as you do for others
and
i i think that that message has been
very
helpful to people at least that's what
they've told me
the i and it's predicated that the rule
is predicated on
the old judeo-christian idea the oldest
idea in some sense that
you know that there's a relationship
between
logos which is truthful speech and
communication and
bringing things into being from chaotic
potential that's
the idea that's put forward in genesis
and also the idea that men and women
alike are made in the image of god which
suggests that
like god we have the capability of
affecting potential affecting the
possible future and turning it into the
actual present and that we do that
at least in part as a consequence of our
ethical choices
the first proposition you know that life
is suffering and that we make it worse
with our malevolence i think everyone
understands that to be true
but the second is that the best way to
confront that
is to shoulder responsibility
voluntarily and to live in truth i think
those are even more powerful ideas
because
you could say that the cure for a
malaise or the treatment for a disease
is more powerful than the
malaise or the disease itself and if
responsibility and truth
are antidotes to suffering and
malevolence then that means that they're
they're of they have a power that's
transcendent over suffering malevolence
you should use a calendar to structure
your days
because if you know what you're doing
tomorrow it decreases your anxiety
substantially because you need that kind
of structure
you need a pathway you need to know you
need to have a map and you need to know
where you're located on the map and you
need to know how you're moving forward
and that
gives you hope because you're moving
towards goals that you regard as
worthwhile and it stops you from being
anxious because you're not entirely
directionless and lost
and so learning how to manage your time
is useful and you can start with a
calendar you can start with simple
things like you can put in
well when you're likely to go to bed and
when you're likely to get up
and and regulating that's useful that
should be relatively
ritualistically consistent first of all
i i try to be over prepared in some
sense so
i mean i believe that if you're going to
if you're going to give a 20-minute
lecture you should have an
hour of material at hand because that
way you have an opportunity to sort of
move spontaneously through the material
but generally what i do now because i
have a lot of material
at hand a lot of stories and a lot of
things that i've
acknowledged say that i've accrued over
the years usually before a lecture
also and this is the hard part and i can
do a lecture without doing this but it's
better if i do this this is the hard
part
i'll sit down for 20 minutes with my
eyes closed and
i figure out what the what the central
topic is so there's always a question
what's the question i'm trying to
address in this lecture
and then i'll figure out a pathway
through it it's like okay well
here's the argument here's point one
here's point two here's point three
and there's possible branches off those
and then with each point i usually have
a collection of stories
and facts that i can use to make the
point
and that's the point yeah yeah and then
to buttress it and to make it
interesting and so it's a little bit
it's a little bit like improvisational
jazz i would say or even improvisational
piano because i play a little bit of
piano one
so you lay out the the story and then
right you can use the responses of the
audience to
guide how you're going to walk through
it the aims that you have in your life
the ethical aims
and those are the aims that direct your
actions also direct your perceptions
that this is true at a
neurophysiological level and that
much of the way that the world manifests
itself to you
is a consequence of the structure of
your
ethics so it's your ethical structure
that's instantiated neurophysiologically
that
serves as an intermediary between the
world of
phenomena let's say objective phenomena
and your perception of that and you see
the world through an ethical lens
you know yourself by watching and paying
attention
that's why the egyptians worshiped horus
the eye
as a god they knew that attention was
important and
the mesopotamians did the same thing
with their god marduk it's not
thinking exactly it's not imagination
it's just it's watching like you're like
you're a snake
a snake you know is a symbol of wisdom
in part because
a stink is a symbol of many things but
wisdom is one of them
i suppose it's because encounters with
snakes that
if they're not fatal they make you wise
because a
snake watches like cold-bloodedly
with no emotional reaction just to see
what's there
it doesn't allow symbolically speaking
doesn't allow
what is wanted or desired to interfere
with
what is observed so you watch yourself
like that
as if you don't know who you are i have
a theory that i've been working on
for a very long time and what happens
when i read something is i plug it into
the theory
so i know the full outline of the theory
it's it'd probably take me
45 50 hours to lay it out in lectures
i've done that online and then but i
keep it grows and grows and grows and
grows and i know where to put
everything so if i read something i
think oh yes that slot's
there and so and so you store it as well
if somebody asks you a question you need
to use that fact you have it somewhere
still where you bring it and say okay
but it has to be related to this work
that i've been doing over time
yeah yeah so it's kind of like there
there's this technique called memory
castle that people have used for
centuries to
remember things and so what you do is
you you you
you sit and you you imagine a might be a
place that you know like a lit a
geographic place a house
and then you can place the things that
you remember imagine you walk through
the house you can place the things that
you want to remember at different
locations in the house
but you have to you have to turn what
you're remembering into an image
and then you can walk through the house
and and you can lift things up and find
what it is that you're trying to
remember
i sort of do that with this theory it's
like it's it's
interesting i've literally worked on it
for it's been 40 years and so i know the
i know the story and i know it's
branches and i keep adding to it and
adding to it and
shifting pieces around from time to time
weak people are a problem
in general and i don't mean physically
weak i mean
cowardly let's say and deceitful because
i'm thinking it more in terms of moral
weakness
well there's a variety of reasons is
first of all if you
can't support your own weight let's say
then someone else has to do it and
that's not good
and then if you don't make your pathway
if you don't pick a forthright and
useful
and noble pathway through life then
you'll become bitter
and and and too hurt by the tragedy of
existence and then
you tend to seek your revenge wherever
you can get it and that's not good
so it's a it's a mistake on all fronts
it's not good for you it's not good for
your family
it's not good for the community um it's
certainly not a good medium to long-term
strategy because life is very very
difficult and
you have to be prepared for that and and
i had a a um
a watcher the other night he was at my
lecture in
oslo and he wrote me a letter he was a
17 year old boy
and he said that he that my work had
been very helpful to him
his father had died suddenly about
six months before and he found his dad
when he was dying and was very very
shocked and
horrified and hurt by what had happened
and i had recommended on my
youtube lectures that one thing you
could aim for
was to be the strongest person
at your father's funeral and so that's
what he did
and he helped his mom and he wrote a 200
word eulogy and
got through it and so good for him
that's strength and necessary it's a
terrible thing that happened but
he did everything he could not to make
it any worse than it had to be but do
you never see that
showing weakness can be a strength too
not weakness
vulnerability that's that's a whole
different thing to admit to
to admit to the fact that you're
vulnerable that's a form of courage
that's not a form of weakness
but that leads you to take whatever
steps are necessary to deal with that
properly
it isn't some facade that you're
invulnerable no one is invulnerable
by any stretch of the imagination and to
stand up and face that is
is the best route that you have your
sanity
is socially distributed and what i mean
by that is
well let's say that you know how to
behave you're well socialized
you can play with others now
i said already in this conversation if
you didn't learn to play with others
between the time you were two and four
you will never learn and psychologists
have beat their heads against the wall
trying to rehabilitate
antisocial children they can't do it
after the age of four
is that because areas of the brain just
don't develop
well it seems to be partly because the
kids fall farther and farther behind
so let's say you make the leap from
egocentric dependence on your mother
at two and three to immersion in a peer
group
well then then you you pick peers that
are at your same development level
and you chase each other up the
developmental ladder
and the longer you're out of that the
farther you fall behind
and so you know kids five-year-old kids
might come across another
five-year-old kid who tends to cry too
much
if they don't get their way and they'll
say we don't want to play with the baby
and what they're saying is we have to
find someone who's at our developmental
level shares our developmental horizons
so that we can mutually
scaffold our further development now
they're not going to say that obviously
but that's the situation
and kids test each other out when they
first meet so do adults
game game game game can you play are you
playing at the same level as me
i'm playing my game at the level that
will further my development
can you play along with me if not well
maybe you're lower in status and i can
pull you up
as a mentor maybe you're higher in
status and i can learn from you but if
you're a peer we can play together
anyways if you're acceptable to your
peers
and you behave well they'll accept you
and then they tell you all the time if
you're
acting appropriately you know if your
jokes are funny if you're dominating the
conversation if you're
bringing something of value to the table
and all you have to do is pay attention
to the social cues
and you'll keep yourself regulated all
of the people that i know
who have become successful in any way
use a structured means to
organize their time they have lists of
things to do like they have
every day there's a list of things to do
that day
every week there's a list of things to
do that week every month
there's a list of things to do that
month you know
at every level of temporal resolution
there's a sequence of
plans and those plans are implemented on
a day-to-day basis
you you cannot be and successful isn't
the right way of thinking about it
because
i'm not thinking about you know i'm not
really thinking about rising up the
corporate ladder you know you know what
i mean
and that's sort of what success has come
to mean in our culture
that isn't what i mean you can't have a
life
that you're going to find acceptable
without that because you need the
vision and the plans to give you purpose
and direction that's where all your
positive emotion comes from all your
motivation
is laying out plans that are worth
attaining and then observing yourself
moving towards them that's the source of
most positive meaning
and then also without that structure
you're so lost that you're going to be
anxious and overwhelmed it's really like
being in a foreign country
like isolated and alone with no map
i don't know where the hell i am i don't
know what the hell i'm doing
you know the rains are going to come the
storms are going to come
and maybe it's winter and i don't know
where i am or where i'm going
we actually have a biological instinct
for meaning that orients us in the world
and that instinct manifests itself
when we place ourselves in a position in
the world where
we're competent where what we're doing
is working
so that we're not too terrified and
anxious but also while we're
simultaneously advancing ourselves and
improving our ability to cope with the
world so for example if you watch an
athlete a
high-level athlete who's at the peak of
his or her performance
you see someone who's extraordinarily
practiced at what they're doing and has
developed the expertise necessary to do
it
but then you also see them push
themselves on that
developmental edge to make themselves
just that much better
and that that function is associated
with an intrinsic sense of meaning
and whenever you see anyone manifest
that you you are
automatically drawn to it you you see
that when an actor
pushes him or herself beyond their
limits
you see that when someone speaks
extemporaneously and manages it
extraordinarily well
and i'm trying to help people understand
that this
this meaning is a true phenomenon it's
not
a secondary thing and also to point out
that most of the time
that meaning is associated with the
adoption of responsibility
make friends with people who want the
best for you and
that's a meditation on my own childhood
and adolescence to some degree
i had friends who wanted the best for me
and friends who didn't and
you know they were friends who
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up then
they're generally not that happy about
it you know they try to top your
accomplishment with one of their own
hypothetical or real or put down what
you're doing or offer you a cigarette if
you're trying to quit and you've kind of
done that successfully or a drink if
you've
been drinking too much and are trying to
stop being an alcoholic you know
or or yeah they're cynical and bitter
and
and devoted towards no good and
sometimes that's family members too and
sometimes it's even part of you you know
but this chapter is a injunction to
people is like
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself you have an
ethical responsibility to surround
yourself with people
who have the courage and and
faith and wisdom to wish you well when
you've done something good
and to stop you when you're doing
something destructive
and if your friends aren't like that
then they're not your friends
and maintaining your friendships with
them might not even be in their
interest and so it's a tricky argument
to make because i'm not saying you know
whenever anyone's in trouble you should
you know
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks that's that's not
the idea
the idea is that but i had a couple of
rules i didn't write about one was be
careful
uh be careful about whom you share good
news with and another was be careful
about whom you share bad news with and
everyone
those rules ring in people's minds quite
quickly a friend is someone you can
share good news with you know
you go to them and you say hey look this
good thing happened to me and they say
look i'm so happy
that that happened to you like way to be
and they don't think god damn it why
didn't that happen to me and
like you know you didn't deserve it
here's a bunch of reasons you're stupid
and why it won't work it's like that's
not
helpful and so i would say like if
people are
you know what the other thing people are
doing if they're trying to drag you down
let's say is they're trying to see if
you'll put up with it
because they have this idea that maybe
life isn't worth living and things
aren't good and then if they can
besmirch let's say to use an archaic
term
something that's pristine and good then
they demonstrate to themselves that
there is no true ideal
and that there's no necessary reason to
be responsible and to strive forward
and so they use you as a test case you
know i'll just
push you down into the low lobster bin
and see how you respond and if you put
up with it then yeah
my cynicism is fully justified make one
room in your house as beautiful as
possible
that's that's what i'm writing about now
i talked a lot about already about the
necessity of cleaning your room
which is you know in some sense a
foolish piece of advice because it seems
so obvious but
it's not obvious at all and you'll find
if you try it especially if you're in a
household that's not very functional
that you'll
encounter obstacles that you couldn't
imagine existed
while you're trying to put your life in
order and
you can take your surroundings beyond
order and and and move towards beauty
and that's unbelievably useful because
while beauty calls people to their
higher being i would say and
to make friends with beauty is to
introduce yourself and introduce
yourself very carefully to one of the
mysteries of life that make it worth
living let's say you're a filmmaker and
i'm a professor
okay we could so we differ there right
we're playing a different game
so you might say and and as you go down
into the particulars of what we do it
might even become more different
so if you look at what a plumber does
and a lawyer does as as you get more and
more fine-grained they get more diverse
but you might say well the lawyer and
the plumber are both honest
they're both good citizens and then you
might nest that inside well they're both
acting out the archetype of the hero
and and like i said after that you're
out of the
things get too abstract for us to we
can't go farther than that
i think that you know i think the world
is
order versus chaos let's say the balance
of order and chaos on a
it's good and evil on the background of
order versus chaos
and so you're either the hero or the
adversary or actually most of the time
you're a mixture of both
and it's best for you that's what our
culture has decided
it's best for you to take on the role of
the hero to the degree that that's
possible and that would be associated
with
love and that's that the
love and i define that in the second
book particularly
what's the third book i wrote but in in
beyond order
are you working for the betterment of
being or are you working for harm
and everyone has a sense of this
and they know when they're working for
harm you're going to use what you think
to guide your action and the consequence
of that is going to be how your life
turns out
so i'm dead serious about what i write
because because i know what the pathway
is
it's like you don't you don't
communicate in a false manner because if
you do you'll warp the structure that
guides your actions and you will
absolutely
absolutely 100 suffer for that i mean
one of the things i've learned as a
clinical psychologist
is that i've never seen anyone it's
really a terrifying thing
i've never seen anyone get away with
anything ever
it the chickens always come home to
roost so and sometimes it might you know
let's say you get away with something
it's like yeah you think so man
you wait five years from now seven years
from now it'll come back
is that karma it's more like yes i think
it's the same idea
but it's more like you you can't
you you you don't have the power to
manipulate reality
like you have the power to bring about
reality in some sense because
you confront potential and through your
actions and
and your communicative intent you turn
potential into reality
but you don't have the you don't have
the power to bend reality without it
snapping you don't think so
you don't think so so you don't think
visionaries and influencers have the
ability to bend reality no i don't think
they bend it i think that they
they they i mean you can bring new
things into being
but you can't you can't get away with a
falsehood
no you can definitely bring new things
into being you can't get away with a
falsehood yes that's it
okay makes sense and and you can't get
away with weak thinking either
because i mean any more than you can get
away with improper action it just
doesn't work so
you're you're contending it's what's why
i mean one of the themes in
my writing is the danger of falsehood
and at any at every level it's like well
if you tell the truth to the degree that
you can or at least don't lie
i think that's rule eight um then you
have reality on your side you gotta
decide
man you want reality on your side or do
you want reality against you
i wouldn't recommend the whole reality
against you thing
because you're not gonna win you're to
get flattened
and so i'm very careful with what i say
and i'm very careful with what i write
we are thrown challenges
and that there that and that in some
sense those are best construed as
tests of our ethical ability so what
jung thought
his idea was something like this that at
the beginning of time
people were unconscious and that
consciousness emerged with all of its
catastrophes consciousness of death for
example
and one way out of the burden of
consciousness was to return to
unconsciousness
you can do that with alcohol you can do
that by being dependent you can do that
by failing to grow up
you refuse the burden of consciousness
by becoming unconscious again but
there's another way forward which is to
become
even more conscious so the idea would be
a little bit of consciousness is like an
illness but if you can expand that
consciousness upwards enough then it's
time
something it starts to become something
that it's all that
is its own cure and that partly what
your
goal is while you suffer through life is
to heighten your consciousness to the
point where everything gets integrated
enough
so that that's proper medication for the
disease of
self-consciousness because it's one
thing to live properly and that's not a
trivial thing but it's another thing
to be able to articulate yourself and to
be able to negotiate
and generally speaking there's nothing
about that that isn't advantageous
and even introverted and anxious people
can learn to do that
you know it's those are learnable skills
it's not easy but
but but you can manage it you can also
you can also speak carefully you know
and listen to what you're saying and
only try to say things that you think
are true
that's also unbelievably useful you have
to feel that out like
is this really what i believe or am i
putting it forward
well because i want to look good or i
want to dominate or uh
or i want to express obliquely an
emotion that i'm too cowardly to come
out and confront directly or am i being
manipulative
there's lots of reasons that people use
language but what you really should use
it for is
to state what you believe to be true
and then to let the consequences of that
unfold
and so that can also help you
simple truths bluntly stated
can be very powerful you don't need a
lot of verbal fluency
under those circumstances if there's
evidence of strength of character behind
it
look it's good for you to go take your
place in the world have some ambition
have some have a vision have a goal have
a strategy
try to try to be a good person in not
not because
it's your duty precisely because that's
the proper way to live we're in danger
of undermining all of that
and it's not good for people one of the
things that i've really learned for
example
recently is that there's a or learned to
articulate better is that there's a very
tight relationship
between aspiration and responsibility
so let's say well the first question
might be do you need to aspire
to something and the answer is well yes
because you have to do something
okay if you just sit there you'll die
you can't just sit there you have to go
act out in the world
okay so act towards what well that's
whatever your aspiration is you have to
have an aim
okay well what should the aim be well it
should be something worth doing let's
say
what why do something that you don't
feel is worth doing what do you think's
worth doing well if you watch other
people and
you judge when they're doing something
worthwhile you usually judge them
positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves
but you want to be completely useless so
other people have to take care of you
that's pretty pathetic and maybe you
could get your act together so you're
taking care of yourself
and your family and maybe you could even
do better than that and take care of
yourself and your family and your
community
there's lots of ways of defying the
crowd let's say i mean
you could live your life the way that
you want to live it
that's a matter of action you know and
they say actions speak louder than words
and one of the best things you could
possibly be is a
inspirational example so that's not
nothing
um that's that's something live
properly in your defiance of the crowd
right
make your own course allow yourself to
be guided by your own genuine principles
you don't necessarily have to advertise
that which is in some sense what you're
doing
when you when you're debating because
you're taking
the manner in which you act like if
you're an integrated person
and you're articulating that um but
maybe you can't do that because you
don't have the verbal skills well then
the question would be
maybe you should develop some more
verbal skills
like i don't know this for sure dave you
know but but generally it's useful
how do you do that um doesn't hurt to
read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking you need a value
hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well
structured and that there should be
something of divine
importance at the top i would say what
should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that
the most appropriate way of interacting
with potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of briefly
conceptualizing what might be
at the highest pinnacle of the value
structure i would say that's what the
logos is
and so the soul
is a the soul is what
manifests itself in the choice between
different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the
potential of the future into the
actuality of the present
and it does that by making ethical
decisions by choosing between good and
evil at each
choice point and to the degree that it
chooses good
then it takes the raw potential of
the future and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it
does that in a manner that's evil and
contaminated by malevolence and
hatred and vengefulness then it takes a
pathway that
corrupts the world and makes things
worse
and it's the soul that's doing that and
it's the soul that's responsible for
that
and it's also that active part of the
soul that's shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people more
classically have referred to as
character your life doesn't have meaning
without aspiration or name okay so you
need a hierarchy of values
there's got to be something at the top
it's got to be something important
if you don't have that your life doesn't
have any meaning so if you criticize
the hierarchy or even the ideas of idea
of hierarchy
you destroy the idea of aspiration and
then people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily
see if you can put yourself together see
what you can do out in the world
while you're waiting to die it's an all
in game it better be worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility
and aspiration and hierarchy and when
you criticize those things you get rid
of the aspiration
you have to negotiate until you come to
the best solution that can be negotiated
which isn't necessarily a perfect
solution but it might be the best one
that can be done
and then you have to stick with it until
the next negotiation and
if you get upset during the negotiations
which you
likely will because these are difficult
topics how to
divide up responsibilities in the house
and people get mad because they feel
they've been taken advantage of or
aren't being listened to one of the
rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be pushed
through
they have to be negotiated through
because the alternative is
well important things don't get done or
people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or but we know by force
psychological or otherwise on the part
of other people these things have to be
negotiated through
you can tell if you've got the balance
between making peace and speaking the
truth right if the conversation
continues
and it can be emotional and will be and
can be difficult
because important things have to be
dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you
then you've got the balance right you
know and you might have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
gonna
agree until i sleep on it gives you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep
at least to the degree that you can
organize it and
you can often be more solid or more
doubtful about a decision
you need a meaning to sustain you
through the vicissitudes of life
okay well try to debate that it's like
is life painful yes is it anxiety
provoking yes is it uncertain
yes is it painful beyond bearing
sometimes yes it's difficult
everyone agrees about that now they
might disagree about how difficult but
that doesn't matter that the
central point holds okay
what if you think that's all pointless
well that doesn't seem very helpful okay
so you need a sustaining meaning
well where do you find that well
you generally find it in responsibility
to yourself and other people something
that i learned
for example from jean piaget he called
that an equilibrated state an
equilibrated state is like
a game that everyone wants to play and
so if you set your household up properly
then it's a game that everybody is
participating in voluntarily
and that's going to be predicated on the
desire for peace and the willingness to
speak
truth and the ability to take
responsibility so that has to be part of
your higher order moral aim
and then when you're having a difficult
discussion with someone
the discussion is going to be
affected by that higher order moral aim
it's not going to be contaminated to the
same degree by your desire to
inflict pain and attain victory and
you know crush your opponent and punish
them for their previous sins and
um indicate your disappointment things
they've done over the years and all of
that
for knowledge to be yours you have to
integrate it with your own experience
you have to see
how that applies to your own case and
then have a story
to tell about how that's the case that's
personal
right so it's the intermingling of the
abstract with the personal
that makes it real it's the
intermingling of the epic with the
particular or the archetypal with the
with the concrete that makes something
real
and so if an idea is still an
abstraction if you're just parroting it
it also means that you haven't learned
to use it as a tool you haven't started
to apply it in your own life
because you could say well here's an
idea that i came across and here's how i
implemented it and here's what i learned
when i
implemented it and then that's
definitely yours right because
you're you can kind of tell because
you're recounting
your knowledge in a manner that no one
else could do
it and that's what gives it that ring of
genuineness right
that's what it means in some sense to
speak from the heart it's like
well here's my experience with this idea
and you can say too well here's how i
understand this idea
and you reformulate that in your own
terms and that means that you
associate it with your own with the only
with the unique particularities of your
own experience
and then i would also say it means that
you've acted out the ideas and
tested them like in in the world and
that you have
your own stories to tell about that and
and that's how you make it your own now
i've got some special bonus clips that i
think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation
we need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you as the negative
emotion ramps up in intensity
the amount of time that you construe as
manageable shrinks you know and if
you're extremely depressed and
anxious then you know you may be
struggling to get through the day
and then you need a map of
what is going to constitute a minimally
acceptable day
and that might be one where you've done
what you need so that when you wake up
tomorrow things aren't
worse right you have to keep up with
your obligations and your
duties at least enough so that you're
not degenerating downhill
if you want even more motivation from
jordan peterson check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there other things
you're going to be doubtful
about you're not going to know which way
is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do now some
of those you won't stop doing